would you rather sneeze this out of a
gong or sneeze the sound of a bowling
strike how about no sneezing at all
Roman is now offering prescription
allergy relief delivered right to your
door and that's where you want it you
want to see your door you don't have to
go to a pharmacy get Kovac 19
coronavirus all the sick people are in
pharmacies stay at home that's the place
to be go to get Roman dot-com / barstool
to get your medicine today I'm Elijah
Schlesinger and I'm here to answer the
Internet
[Music]
if you only had five dollars to get
drunk what would you buy am I supposed
to say bleach oh I guess yep five
dollars I get some of those mini mini
like patron things that like the tiny
ones that are at the counter at the
liquor store yeah I'm a lightweight
next question my dollar can we can I
gather the interest on that five dollars
and come back to you buy something
substantial would you answer the
Internet do I just answer the internet
every time would you rather be 15 or 50
feet I'm sorry doesn't say that that's
not tall sorry I saw that guy was taller
and I thought it was a tall question
would you rather be 15 or 50 for the
rest of your life well when I was 15 I
didn't have this nose so but when I'm 50
yeah okay no I would say 15 because then
I'd have more energy and they'd be like
this young girl is so smart and she's
she knows a lot about sex for a 15 year
old might be like I'm generations Eve's
see me on tick-tock would you rather be
the most attractive person in the world
but blind the best singer in the world
but deaf I don't know how that's gonna
work or the best chef in the world but
have no sense of taste well I don't want
to be [ __ ] blind so that's just not
practical who cares what other people
think of me I don't need to be a singer
and you need it's preferable to be able
to hear so but no sense of taste neither
that's awful why don't they say like but
like be the best porn star but not be
able to feel because I picked that one
would you rather have your mom send you
a nude or have her send all of your
friends a nude I don't care either way
we can do it right now I've seen my mom
naked
so she posing for it or is it just it's
not like office security cams I wouldn't
mind seeing my mom I'd let have her son
all my friends in nude because she's a
beautiful woman
and it would [ __ ] up their day okay
would you kill baby Hitler if it had to
be in a very gruesome way [ __ ] yeah last
name is Schlesinger like off with your
head
then smash it the fact that he was a
baby like who cares Oh a sacred evil
baby although one could argue are you
pre cogging it you don't know that he
would have grown up to be Hitler did he
come out with the mustache so that's a
science yeah its nature versus nurture
but why can you Hitler would you rather
lose a leg you guys these are awful
would you rather these aren't even fun
like pineapple on pizza or no fight me
would you rather lose a leg or never be
able to have sex again I'm sorry baby
I'd rather never be able to have sex
again
I need my legs to have sex would you
rather have to always wear jeans or
shorts I I guess jeans I already always
wear jeans I seldom wear shorts oh this
one is it's pretty close to home this is
the lamest question aku's like oh that's
a thinker would you rather go back to
being 18 years old knowing everything
you know now or get a million dollars oh
I go back to being 18 so hard still fix
the nose but like I would go back so
hard and I'd be like look at how funny I
am look at all my observations what a
phenom wait what oh um no there's no
amount of money I don't know what then
what I like living new by and I have a
silver camel like who cares I have
enough money that it's fine I have my
assistant which you all made fun of me
for do that so far maybe like two
million you can turn any movie into a
porno with the same cast from the movie
which movie are you picking like who's
hot but like Alan Arkin is in it also I
think Mark Wahlberg's like over me
talking about how hot he is so but like
why would anyone be over that I got
lipstick on this who's hot in a movie oh
okay but then you get ugly people like I
want to say Mad Max is Tom Hardy so hot
but then you get like that weird dude
with the nipple chains on the white hair
bucket you know I'll take one for the
team
what would you pick to be the title of
your autobiography I think we said it
best earlier from Blanche - Tianfu no I
think the title my own photography would
and this is assuming that I'm dead so I
wrote it and then I died and I think I
would call it that was it
marry [ __ ] kill okay oh hey Channing
Brad Pitt Matthew McConaughey or
Channing Tatum
I dunno Channing Tatum and so that's
weird that I'm gonna kill him marry [ __ ]
kill well Brad Pitt's had a rocky go of
it lately now I think McConaughey seems
pretty okay I guess I would oh I don't
want okay I talked a lot about okay so
Matt marry Matthew McConaughey about
Channing Tatum
that's so weird cuz we had a meeting I
don't want to kill Brad Pitt but Oh or
is it like kill maybe the fashion could
be called Brad Pitt and I like kill it
that's my line I'm interpreting it my
own way
I'll kill someone that hot if you got a
one time pass to do whatever you wanted
what crime would you commit murdering
baby Hitler thank you guys
you